all right good morning i'm lieutenant
ray spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department
i'm out here this morning to brief you
on a homicide investigation that we are
conducting in the 9200 block
of south park street which is a
residential neighborhood near the
intersections of blue diamond
and fort apache the details that i have
are preliminary but at around
7 45 this morning metro dispatch
received a 9-1-1
call from a teenager who lives inside
the residence behind me
that teenager reported that he heard
gunshots inside of his house
he went outside of his bedroom into the
hallway and found his mother suffering
from a gunshot wound
at the bottom of this that was at the
top of the staircase at the bottom of
the staircase he found his father
also suffering from a gunshot wound what
we believe
to have occurred is that this is a
murder-suicide investigation
that was a result of an argument taking
place inside of the
house right now we have trauma
intervention for
tips on scene speaking with the family
we are also
speaking with other family members in
regards to some prior
family dynamics as far as what led up to
the shooting so at that point i will
take a couple questions but again it's
still very early on in the investigation
a husband and wife do you know yes it is
a husband and wife
both in their mid-40s
yes the the husband shot the wife
uh before a self-inflicted gunshot to
himself
notice there's been a murder suicide in
henderson there was also another case of
a murder suicide that you were involved
in recently
do you have any thoughts on is this a
trend or what's your thoughts on that
well again it's one of these you know
we're all dealing with the restrictions
of covet and the
current economic environment there's a
lot of stress out there there are
multiple resources out there that family
members can turn to
you can call one one you can also reach
out to the family justice center there's
again
a lot of free resources out there for
families that are under tremendous
stress
in an effort where those resources could
potentially prevent
a situation like this from happening i'm
sorry if you said it the age of the son
he's a teenager their daughter
was also here the only people who were
present at the time
was the teenage son and the mother and
father
all right thank you guys appreciate it
they both are diseased
yes they are both deceased inside the
house thank you all right thank you